au delà de la proposition fantaisiste
d'anne hidalgo de doubler le salaire des
profs immédiatement blanc caire c'est
bien qu'il ya un problème le ministre de
l'éducation nationale lui propose
d'augmenter progressivement sur cinq ans
ce salaire mais on voit bien un salaire
minimum ses 1700 8 euros nets la
proposition du gouvernement c'est de
revaloriser à 1869 euros en début de
carrière le problème c'est que les
écoles ferment depuis 2009 4700 écoles
ont fermé et il ya de plus en plus
d'élèves et je ne vois pas comment
l'équation peut faire que l'éducation va
être de qualité si on ferme des postes
si on a du mal à recruter parce
qu'évidemment c'est un métier qui peine
à recruter là encore est que les élèves
sont de plus en plus nombreux on a
l'impression d'ailleurs que hôpital
école c'est un peu le même schéma qui se
met en place c'est à dire faire plus
avec moins une économie du flux une
économie aussi qui doit être ouvert au
privé et pas forcément aux services
publics avec des agents publics
maltraités je suis d'accord avec vous et
ça se manifeste notamment dans les
démissions des enseignants ce qui est
non seulement le fait qu'il y ait moins
de vivre aujourd'hui c'est que même si
c'est pas c'est pas de gigantesques non
plus en chiffres bruts mans tout casser
ça a été multipliée je crois par trois
ou quatre depuis dix ans ce type de
démission c'est à dire qu'avant ça
l'arrivée très peu puisque un
désavantage des enseignants c'est
d'avoir un post avis la sécurité de
l'emploi et c'est aussi ça qui
recherchait et certain confort dans
l'aménagement des horaires mais qu'ils
se sentent comme beaucoup de français
comme beaucoup de professions de plus en
plus mal traités par ce monde où ils
sont mal payés par l'état pas reconnu et
où parlons-en aussi un petit peu il ya
aussi l'agressivité qui vient du côté
des élèves et des grands justes qui se
répand et des parents aussi qui se
répand de plus en plus et on l'a vu sans
parler du cad à freud et le samuel baty
on voit comment les professeurs sont de
moins en moins protégé par l'état par
laquelle leurs employeurs qui sont de
moins en moins suivi et d et que leur
fonction qui était censée être celle de
l'autorité de celle qu'on respecte les
de moins en moins mais comme comme on le
voit pour les policiers par ailleurs
pour les juges aussi bref il ya aussi
qu'ils se jouent dans la société c'est
pas uniquement
l'état qu'il est père est moins bien
c'est aussi à ce respect a disparu
[Musique]